um for you man um talk to me about like
you know I know uh the focus is Michael
yep how
many times have you been in with LP in
the last like 12 months working on music
if if
any man we've been together cuz we were
touring we haven't worked on any
talkinging you guys had the Tour by the
way I'm still very mad that the rage
tour never happened for me to see with
my own eyes man I I wish you would have
New York K and and I'm glad Zack is
healed up back on the minut and congrats
to all the guys they got int introducted
in the Rock and Roll Hall of Fame
rightfully so yeah the way Runner Jews
usually work is L Trax off into the W
you know he TS off into the Wilderness
somewhere and probably like kills bears
and eats them and lives as a wild man
and then comes back with a plethora of
be I feel like you'd be the guy to kill
bears and eat them n I'm I'm definitely
down to kill [__] and eat it usually we
prefer killing deer and hog where I'm
from but I just went hog hunting with
that Mexican OT we you had fun out Texas
you had we had a ball right it was so
much fun who dressed who dressed them
for you they already had someone on site
to dress the hall cook and make sausages
all that for you well not cook we just
killed them and left them no that's what
we did no you're not supposed to do that
I swear to God this out in Texas they're
like pests I don't no but you're you're
supposed to [__] eat them it's a hog
you're not supposed so we so we killed a
couple of them and then we came back and
like a pack of coyotes or something
destroyed them yeah that's good yeah I'm
just saying you're not you know I know
they're like get so feral out there but
you kill I kill something I'mma eat it
like I'm sorry I'm not sports fishing
I'm not putting a [__] bass Back That
Bass get call That Bass getting at
that's my grandfather say I'm adding it
you know so yeah no I mean I kind of
felt I mean cuz I've never been that's
the only time I ever been hunting you're
good though you should do that it was
fun everyone should do it at least you
know at least gets out once a year do
something we also were doing it out of a
helicopter yeah I've seen it I've seen
it um Kor shouts out to Kor who I
interview years he um he he he go I saw
him I've seen him go out and lean out
the helicopter video of him I was
[__] spooked that [__] was dope yeah
Andy we we're going on a hunting tangent
uh back to you and LP so LP he goes out
and he kills bears and does whatever he
yeah and he comes back with a plethora
of Beats on a hard drive like like what
do you think and and what what I think
is usually oh [__] this is the [__]
album and like sequence and everything
damn near like oh my God this is it and
then from there it's
and then we just in there we just in
there was vibing more than writing we
just start playing [__] like he came out
here we were out here I forgot when it
was it might have been a year or might
have been just over but he came out we
were in different hotels but he came
over um to a spot I was at and he just
played something for me and he had part
of R verse on I said oh let me let me
let me get in there and um I went in
there man I spazzed on that [__] like
I'm like oh [__] so you know to me I'm
just like I want to finish that one and
whenever we finish that one
we might get rtj 5 I mean it's it's got
to happen one day that's something I
cheer for but again we're just you know
it's it's when it's going to happen like
when it happens but until it happens if
you're looking for a Dre verse Michael
or if you're looking for one half I got
LP verse I got both of them on and it's
like and even the record with LP on the
album is like different for y we got
good dope on the street that's all I'm
telling you man we still here for you
man you want to hear run the jewels you
need to listen to don't let the devil
it's a it's a no ID beat with a LP Chop
on different LP chopped it so yeah and
Taco Taco was on the drums on there
right yep little Shalamar who's who's
one of the run the Jews co-producers he
was on there so yeah man so I got the
dope you do man come get the dope man
come run it up um yo have do you see my
tweets like once every two months I
tweet that you should run for
president probably have you seen these
tweets I swear every two months I'm
tweeting will Killer Mike just run for
president I don't want them to kill me I
want to rap I want to build some
business would you ever like like I know
you've as been asked if you'd ever run
for office but like I could see somebody
getting elected eventually and making
you a part of their
cabinet you know what I remember when I
think one of the bushes put Arnold
Schwarzenegger on their cabinet over
physical fitness and that's one thing
I've seen in my life I said that made
all the sense in the world yeah because
you see Arnold and you're like yeah I'm
like putting a brain surgeon who I have
an enormous amount of respect for over
housing Urban Development was a little
quirky for me but Dr Ben Carson grew up
in the housing projects right I would
have liked to have seen Dr Ben Carson
while he was over the housing projects
Institute some type of mandate that that
gave kids options and benefits for
learning who's doing that now budha
Buddha Pete is it Pete no I thought Pete
was doing Transportation or something I
could be wrong he could be over but but
I always thought that that was an
opportunity missed because I thought
that if Ben could have figured something
out between a bank between Health hood
and um education that we could have been
educating kids right in the housing
projects differently so if I did
something in the cabinet that made sense
I'd be honored to but I doubt so you so
you'd be open to that I'd be I'd be open
to that because I could I could do
something effective and I wouldn't have
to prostitute myself for money because
the person that hired me would have
already done that like had the DNC not
like [__] over Bernie Sanders I feel
like you'd be you would definit you
would definitely would have been in the
cabinet yeah I was really believer you
know and whatever the old guy was even
if I wouldn't have been in the cabinet I
would have helped
I would have helped in any way and you
guys it's crazy because like you are
such a leader and I feel like you know
when I think of like um the word
activist that as a word that gets thrown
around um and I I think about like how
you and Bernie show up to like the
Amazon stripes down in Alabama yeah you
know what I'm saying like um that's
something that like you're working on
albums you're touring but like somehow
you still find the time you still find
the energy to like still stand up and
and and just be the voice the vo well
you know what no man it's not just me
you know and and I consider myself a
product of the worker class in this
country I am you know both my dads my
grandpa my my grandma you know Working
Class People hardworking decent people
filled with Integrity good morals and
they just want it better if they made
mistakes they learned from those
mistakes and push forward so you know
for me I'm not the only one you know
when you when you look at senat Nina
Turner I feel like she should be the
leader of the Progressive Movement in
this country you know I I think think
that for us to talk about and I'm
talking about my community not in the
black community for us to talk about
progression and not be talking about her
actively is damn near crime like what's
wrong with us it's like ignoring Malcolm
in the 60s which people did they did you
know the people ignored Malcolm and
after he was dead all of a sudden he had
more fandom and because of people like
Dick Gregory you know when people say
celebrities don't mean much because of
people like dick Gregory's name stayed
alive people like Spike Lee his name
stayed alive so for me you know my thing
is Tesla figuro who now pops up on The
Breakfast Club you know has her has her
has her own um podcast and is also does
work with Revolt teslin is an amazing
political mind and part of the reason I
stay you know um just in know of what is
is because I constantly communicate with
people like Nina I constantly
communicate with Nina with teslin you
know Jennifer farman is amazing
publicist out of the Barney campaign
system black woman out Ohio in but is
brilliant when it comes you know so my
thing is stay in touch with the people
doing the work and less of an organizer
now because my my day job takes me away
but more of a mobilizer how do you get
people there by the time Dr King was
maybe 2 three years before he got out of
you know here and was assassinated by
this part this government is my belief
um Dr King was a mobilizer when he show
up they knew people were going to show
up but people organizing on the ground
included people like John Lewis included
people like Reverend James orange
included people like stokeley carmichel
you know you know also known as quame T
that's who we need we need more of y'all
right you know I I'd love for another
killer mik to pop along you know what I
mean but until that happens you got to
congratulate the people that are working
their ass off to try the best they you
know try to be the best they can be and
I think that they are worthy of our
support locally but look hyper local I
want to tell people that don't be so
enamored by what the television is
telling you to argue about be involved
with the the counil the hyperal before
you even get to your councilman what are
your 10 neighbors think of the street
see I I learned this first from my
grandmother my grandmother didn't like
the way sanitation was leaving people
garbage cans or something on the street
she she didn't think enough care concern
right and so she took it to city council
she was angry about it and she would
didn't get satisfied what she heard so
she went and sat in the mayor's office
till he saw her she literally just went
and sat in here until until she complain
and she still didn't get what she wanted
and within two weeks we were on Channel
5 news with my grandmother saying this
is how they do the black folks black
community all of a sudden we've never
had issues with sanitation again cuz
that black mayor it wants to get elected
that black city council person and they
say they want to do good for the black
community well put our barbish cans down
respectfully cuz we respectful people we
clean our yard and and it just she was
my hero in that fashion and I Want More
Heroes like that because that's the way
you create a killer you create a fanny L
HR you you you know you you create you
create all these people that care that
Aid the people that may be the tip of
the spear you know Bayard rushing you
you create these people by being
hyperactive so whoever ever on a local
level in your town is doing something
take some time to help them out